diamo ragazzi ebbe verde questo video di
happy with sì io sono la vj e oggi siamo
su l'ho appena detto qual è il problema
mio ultimamente ho mai gallo ragazzi o
stai con cui sono quei livelli un po un
po strani che ti permettono di
cazzeggiare parlare della tua vita nel
minor aaron analoghi godete il la
bellezza e l'estro di questo livello che
ha fatto addirittura in 3d pensa alte
siamo nel 2020 e fa vice riporta giochi
in tre dice voi dove lo trovi uno
youtuber migliore ma chi sono gli altri
youtube per chi sono gli altri due
spiega allora a parte delle cagate di
oggi sembra sto bene sto livello
ovviamente perché siamo nella lista tra
di veli pasti decentemente tipo questo
però devo andare poi giù qualcosa vi
dice di sì ma l'ho scoperto un po troppo
in ritardo va bene allora per ora tutto
a posto
non è vero
meno male che ha detto che era tutto a
posto per ora tutto a posto
gli allora fatto dottor banca gratis che
un parecchie di banca top in totale oggi
giocava il gioco di sangue è vero che
riuscirà a farla roba decente visto che
il tackle corso mi faccio da quando
avevo 16 anni che ho iniziato a fare il
viso di un orco il demonio molto bene
per i gay come il tasto non lo faremo
perché mai livello che è il non sente
presente quando cliccate lo schermo
inattesi per schiacciare i pulsanti mica
l'hanno messo subito ci sarò perché tu
puoi cliccare lo schermo semplici ci
hanno messo anni permettono dalla tenevo
lana fisher incredibile come sa essere
inventato loculi vabbè andiamo avanti
per ora tutto a posto
denis lazzari in versione dopo
l'aggiunta del mese la carta di frozen
no non puoi che c'è copie però avrei
cantato volentieri bisogna vedere se
riesco a fare perfetto come sono bravo
mi sono già speso qui sono spiazzato
lega mero fatto niente non ho fatto
nulla se non iniziare soli ma è perfetto
non iniziamo il tele di happy be healthy
per favore già scritto bene l'ho visto e
l'importante arrivare alla fine tutto
ciò problema è che allora posso farvi
una dichiarazione vera e propria sue b
bis c'è una cosa che nonostante tutti
gli animi ancora abita ancora più
sinistro gioco sono le bombe io ve lo
giuro le bombe su lewis
siamo tutti calmi le bombe su s
ancora non riesco a non mi dà un
fastidio perché non riesco ancora a
gestirle e sono passati mille anni però
di stare calmo e leve gerswhin gable
offline ma subisce noto a inglesi
madonna che ansia ma che diavolo che
ricalchi caverna è questa scala where
the frozen la caverna strana ghiacciata
non vedo niente di ghiacciati
allora solo all'inizio grazie un salve
quindi sei stato tu che ha invaso la mia
caverna e sto fatto il mio master e
shawn times non lo fare chi la fa
l'aspetti questo lato massone shaun time
posso tornare indietro
questa cosa sto giocando quanti problemi
questo video questa la mia chiave del
frozen giaime rai c'è il masso page e
brin china in idem non traducete questa
gol e durevole ko valanga dove stia
infine in tutto ciò collocazione in
attacco è una versione alternativa di
penombra questo gioco che si millanta
chi lo guarda trame la stessa masturba
action pizjuan livello fatto da sono
veramente annoiato ma figurati se invece
avete voglia di fare qualcosa tu era mai
ott io ci sono due nudi
buongiorno gente nuda scusate noti o
rosso il bene ai ragazzi non mi dispiace
non volevo farlo mi piace che i livelli
quelli elaborati con questi sono usate
cosa fa la sua dobbiamo vincere questa
battaglia ma oggi non è ma non è questo
il giorno va bene buongiorno io non
faccio domande ma domani i believe di
farmi spiegare cosa succede
si chiama the anti robbins hai sempre
ridotto con ely sbancato fede il
fratello
salve lei che è impiantato al muro mi
dice qual è il problema ho visto uno che
volava prima ma non ho capito salve
anche a lei che vola per che impiantano
la gente come i lampadari non sono fatti
con le persone ve lo spiego io se avete
un gusto e arredamento del fa veramente
schifo
kate actimel o se è successo che gately
che gate non ho capito
dove devo andare aiuto non dalla
sinistra a eccoci kate attive c'è un
tombino con salve c'è un tizio morto per
terra e vale un pulsante cerca dei sei
già morto ma tu sorella ma vai a
chiamare hanno capito che incontra i
topi nella fogna che vivono che sono già
morto ma nessuno e gentile come
ratatouille tutti i topi do con successo
in realtà turisti montati la testa pure
nelle fogne che è scattata la foglia u
salve voi vivete cosa o dio c'è un
carlino
c'è un po perché avete un carlino qui
sotto cosa fate voi due uova in elena
della human being io sono maria questo
marito
i robot hanno preso controllo del mondo
bisogna l'abbiamo seguita per aiutarci
devi trovare modo per distruggere tutti
i robot si però non inglobate mi vuoi
mettere in salvo il mondo che i bravi
ragazzi
a cosa sto giocando ragazzina di prego
che trama incredi detroit become human
fatto bene perché la tela fatto male
devo salvare il pianeta sono uno con un
motorino no schiacciato una morte ora
però la volpe
mettilo come titolo del video fa
vincendo il futuro ma perché hanno
schiacciato una volpe teste di ca no
potete toccarmi gli esseri umani ma non
le volpi mensili culo sono bellissime
what does the fox ei lancieri nasco
frittata in faccia frutti pezzenti che
odiate gli animali da oggi verranno
trovati diventato alla ricetta blade
runner siamo da detroit alla ricerca di
nemo è una teoria devo fare qua e quindi
due siamo finiti scusa sono annegato
nell'acqua ma no
ma cosa ma come ma c'è un finale o no ma
e deve andare così per forza e sono qua
quindi
non si sono sprecati a fare un finale
perché ovviamente come fai a salvare il
mondo dai robot dopo che ammazzano le
volpi non lo so quindi il livello
finisce così tutto molto triste
next level fatevi sfoga biking
stravedevo sfogarmi proprio test sono
sufficientemente sfogato cosa devo fare
qui porco devo fare una roba
dove sono i vichinghi già scritto
fighting 3 eccoli teste di culto dalla
collana di dubbia bellezza mi dai una
mano per favore mi devo fare qua magari
andare di sotto che non c'è un carro ma
sono entrato dentro minore aveva bene
solo vivo non sono vivo diventare il
carro la vedo che sono capito inside e
carro che andava avanti per fatti miei
farai copriti compiti che fa prendo
qualche tipico effetto modo la b e prima
che il bmw dei vichinghi non so cosa sia
successo però solo l'ho vinto io
salve buongiorno signora ha bisogno di
dire la carica in macchina che quale c'è
la macchina della salvezza dall'altra
[ __ ] santo si chiama di secondo
c'era un ninja nell'albero signora mi
dispiace unexpected riproviamoci in
attivo che questo mi sembra fatto bene
anche perché c'è un lieto fine la
signora la porta di san donà portiamo in
azione del genere non potete colpirmi
sono in macchina scusatemi signora mi
scusi sto arrivando di nuovo
vediamo se in qualche modo l'anno
importunata signora vado avanti veloce
mi scusi che c'è un uomo nell'albero con
lucida ecco infatti la tornerò a
prenderla glie lo prometto qualche modo
non so come capolino decente dalla
collina proprio lui che scappa planare
di viking dimenticato la signora devo
salvarla fa niente lieto fine ragazza
happy source oh mio dio dark souls level
voti ne piglia non l'ho finito
ve lo dico io però andiamo si proviamoci
da un tentativo prendo l'anima l'anima
di un padre il responsabile va bene
chiave del cancello bene forse invece
c'è chiave di un ragazzo senza 9 maschia
ma è il titolo io anima di ieri hanno
detto chiaro gli anima prove salve
l'oncia che che viene stato fa niente
tanto capita tutti i giorni
non si può andare io ho la chiave del
cancello posso proseguire
non c'è anche sveglia rifarle spaccate
sui cancelli io posso proseguire togliti
disarcionati this arpionati da me ho
usato la chiave del cancello a posto
seguimi no no alla conquista di dark
souls usato il nonno come sono morte
uguale lo stavo usando come barriera ma
non è servito tantissimo veri proviamo
ve lo dico ai ragazzi questo non è taxos
non giocata dal sol perché è scoprire
nuovo lessico coniato dai modi germano
mosconi ancora andare a giocare non
giocata dal sold ragazzi lasciamo che
cadono dalle scale da soli vogliamo
cercare dalla fine salve sono vivo la
occhio lascia ossia lascia occhia lascia
pravo che lei prese in faccia perfetto
signori non sono riuscita e dark souls è
in fini bile anche con la normale quindi
sono contento di aver registrato un
episodio perché poi riuscirò a finirlo
ma non è questo il giorno ho già detto
prima giocagiocattolo scherzando poi se
riuscite a finirlo provate episodi è un
po più difficile però non impossibile
provano magari nostro bisogno di farlo
ma per ora mi fermo qua ci sono andato
abbastanza bene questo gene non la dico
mesi tanti livelli ma oggi andata bene
non ridicolizzano c oltre avevo già
fatto tanto ricordati non fatele mare
gli animali anche alle volpi porca vacca
che l'hanno investita li maledizione
finiamo la prima che scenda di più nel
trash tutto questo bei ragazzi
[Musica]